three wins and you are in the grand
finals but only one of these two players
will make it loser will get third place
and we are going to the dragon's nest
oh yeah it always gets to touch the
floor man because that's when he's about
to get crazy he's gonna start
breakdancing nice counter hit down
forward three to up three
he's just checking the surface he's like
oh yeah i can break dance on this yep i
can do it on this
like oh can i back dash on this yup
let's go
like you said that i was in my head i'll
take all breakdancing so like can i do
flare so i'm like oh yeah no he's gonna
back dash
oh yeah
i mean look at that shuffle he's just
going dude he's
this looks like is this game broken
what's happening
he's dancing all over the place oh my
did you see that that was crazy what uh
that was eddie oh he dropped the ender
oh okay never mind he's good he's good
yeah uh i feel like calum
is confident in the matchup the way he's
moving it's like he's he's been there
done that yeah and that that desperation
hop kick from dvk at the end didn't
really give do him any favors right in
the back here what are you gonna do oh
my gosh i don't think he was ready for
that exactly i'll just say i get these
characters that have these weird spring
kicks would they end up back turned to
you if you block it you got to be ready
to like destroy them right take like 50
percent of health because you can get a
full watch on them
bro callum looks so
prepared for this okay never mind yeah
as soon as i said that man it's the
curse thing that they talk about that
commentator's curse
rick's the claims it's not real
uh
i i think it's different too especially
when if you do commentary but you also
play
like i don't know how you feel
because like your curse the curse that
you did to feed the extras is kind of
real
i i even i heard about that i wasn't
even part about that one was that like i
felt like i cursed him as soon as i said
it i was like oh boy oh
why did i say that
all right here we go he's going to keep
him there dvk
has a huge life lead here and then calum
right now he can't really back that's
too much he has the wall right behind
him
we haven't seen that sweep yet so far in
the competition so right now dvk pulling
off to the lead callum what you're gonna
do that was actually such a risky choice
when you think about it right
like yeah sleep there get a big life
lead why would you write that you kind
of got launched and you know this is
again depending on the different players
in different regions we see a different
type of
tone of the match in a different type of
pacing uh more often than not we've seen
a lot of lows at the end of rounds we we
see ankles getting hurt and some plus
low prairies and low ducks
yeah
here we go nice punish there with the
jabs
man callum is just in and out
we've been in and out of traffic and he
hit him with that
big launch to follow up here he's gonna
get the wall the back two three three
one more hit close it out
rage drive
takes his turn back
see what he does this is important gotta
watch out times are wasting oh my god
that was so sick and just because of
that he is going to win the match
what a hop kick
that was impressive that is a
beautifully placed top kick right there
that's what i like to see very nicely
done dvk getting it done the first game
with miguel here slow and easy is the
way i want to hop kick tonight
that was good stuff good hop kick
and just like that
first match again this is a race to
three
still not over by a long shot but i feel
like callum the way he was kind of
playing and moving he was in cruise
control for a long time but again
clutching it out is another thing
he felt he felt comfortable with the way
he was moving in and out but it wasn't
enough it wasn't enough and that's the
thing is like sometimes you got to play
uh and like yeah back dashing see back
cashing is good right
you know what what's the bad thing about
back dashing
it doesn't do damage that's very true no
doubt it doesn't do damage until you get
a whiff punish right yeah you gotta get
the whiplash which he has shown that he
can do he can do it right
but again
it's just part of the puzzle
yeah the other thing i really like about
his back dash is it seems like a lot of
his opponents they get really flustered
by it like they're like dude he's not
doing i have to go do something you know
and they come in and they they just put
too much in line these boom counter it
down for two you know so yeah i feel
like that's a big deal here you got to
be patient uh when you go against an
eddy player that's just back dashing all
day don't give that opportunity because
you know they're waiting for it yeah
that's one of the strengths though i
feel like for eddie as well is like
sometimes you want to frustrate your
opponent kind of annoy them and then
have them kind of go for their bigger
longer advancing attacks but that's like
prime real estate for you to throw out
the counter hit down forward to throw
out the counter at back three three it's
uh it kind of fits in with the play
style and
as a player you have to
kind of like buckle down and like not
fall for it
have that patience
anyways we are going to violet systems
this is one of the longer stages at
least on one side uh and we'll see how
it plays out here
yeah definitely one of my favorite
stages
it's the combats for me
did the combos do it yeah that's the
combos
i mean you can think about a lot of
mochajin man
i don't know man combined in mokugen
that that's a that's a tough one
bokugen's book engine in the game he's
like a
an item that you could add on to
characters oh please
he's also a character panel
he's in there i think the other i think
that is my current uh
character panel actually there you go
now i'm off the good lead here in game
two round one
keep it solid nice
nice go for the size of three plus four
unable to get anything out of it
calum was looking really good obviously
with a little bit more room to work here
but still has the benefit of walls let's
see what he does nice support for and
this is something that we haven't really
seen from him in the spacing game so far
the l4 has a little bit better range
than some of the other pokes that he's
been using but again he has to be kind
of aware just on how on its use nice
sites before
eddie doesn't really have the best lows
he has a lot of them i'll say that he
has a lot of lows
a lot of scary lows but not the best
lows when it comes to like breaking down
your opponent
yeah there's just more for the noise but
look at the punish there
that while standing
all right good knock down there from dbk
he still got the life lead here time
still plenty
i like the way he's sidestepping
readjusting this is gonna hurt
not gonna kill but one more sequence
could do it
dbk he has to rage drive if he gets that
low
oh wow i didn't expect that that came
out of nowhere that was nice
uh but callum good defense holds on
boots
and he's gonna get the wall too what's
he gonna do here
oh the splat
oh yes
uh-huh the follow-up here he gets the
head noggin
hit him with the diddy bop what's he
going to do
that pressure but he went for the power
cushion with no light
yeah oh
man
maybe he got too much of a of a flow
there
uh just what he's used to because i mean
it's a great move to use by the wall
right but you need to have life that's
the the the weakness of the power
crushes yes it can go through moves but
it also still takes life
exactly
uh but calum answering back there with
the eddie uh yeah kind of expected it
you know i honestly thought the way the
first game was going that callum was
gonna get that one as well right so uh
the fact that he even up here not
unexpected but
uh we'll see how this whole set plays
out i'm really curious because this
first three it's a long set there's
still a chance that dvk could switch
characters here uh but
i think so far the miguel's working out
what do you think went wrong for him in
that second game
it just i i think it was a combination
of things it's he got impatient and you
know a lot of what we saw in the first
game you know he he clutched it out and
his clutch was not present at all
there and he just put himself in a lot
of situations where it was interesting
because you know like eddie's back was
to the wall a lot of the time right
because of whether it was back dashing
or just combo spacing or whatever but he
didn't attack he didn't get in and one
of the things that we saw early on is he
went for a lot of those lows and this
time obviously getting blocked getting
launched with the ball standing 1-3 i
feel like it's a matter of timing and
also using threatening mids by the wall
because you know miguel has a ton of
mids that could wall splat as well he
has a a very
good i think arsenal of mid attacks that
can be very threatening but it's all
about using him i mean he hasn't i mean
if you think about it he hasn't been
using a lot of moves at all
yeah he's been trying to play the same
kind of patient gameplay but
uh doing the same thing like that
against eddie when he's got such a
better back dash
uh you know it's a hard game to play for
sure and i think miguel definitely
excels at a closer range game
so you know closing in on eddie is going
to be one of the question marks and as
you mentioned if anything's gonna be
back dashing all day he's gonna hit the
wall this stage here a little bit larger
a lot more angles to work with uh which
could help in
helping eddie screw up his rage art and
make him go the wrong direction we'll
see if that comes into play
maybe it will maybe we'll we'll see
anyways they're gonna go right into it
tied up one a piece right now again a
longer set a race to three between these
two
we're in the forbidden temple grounds
here
as these players battle it out and i
like what i'm seeing here so right now
calum is kind of actually fighting up
close he does have a slight life lead
but now dvk starting to open him up
there's a running boot to the face
yeah chop those ankles
boo
the power chris i got plenty of help
this time
yeah made it count and right now dbk
taking that first round i like what i've
seen too because he's also using the
throws to kind of pressure and we saw
early on oh my gosh
that was the right thing to do but it
wasn't close enough
[Music]
does uh
miguel's hopkin get there on relax
it can't hit and relax okay but you have
to be close enough closer right yeah
oh here we go
interesting goes for that load just get
some damage
yeah this up up close game man
ever the aggressor right now man it's
been paying off so far there's load the
follow-up here into the mid attack dvk
is
taking control right now this is the way
he needed to play back then like you
can't back dash with the when the wall's
there what are you gonna do
nice nice that was a good block i mean
it could have been a bad punish right
there too yep
oh no
yeah and you know that he knew he was
gonna end up right in front of him but
still late there
and now callum
good life lead here down two rounds but
you can't count him out we saw the crazy
stuff he had earlier oh my gosh
everything's hitting
the block of the lawn he's dead he's
there
yes mark's gonna come short do the wager
early so you get less scaling on it
should be enough to have to kill them
boom there's the round for calum hey can
i uh interest you in some cutscene would
you like to watch i love some
give me more all right how are you
looking for the power crush good stuff i
mean you have to go for a faster move if
you want to get the float there
the power crush can activate pretty fast
from a handstand position
[Music]
uh-huh there we go he hasn't used that
either right the 3-2
[Music]
yeah which i think is a great tool
overall yeah
gotta test your opponents here's the
follow-up
dvk again
has the wall positioning
oh
nice
ford ford for follow-up
oh he's getting confidence right now
what's with the grab looking at it out
of here
yo look at that very dominant round the
aggression is really what to come over
it's a kind of take control of the match
up and just like that callum is in
trouble i gotta say it straight up right
now before we get into the next match
callum cannot play like that i don't
know what the difference is here other
than maybe the aggression from dbk but
calum really needs to start fighting
back and there's a lot of tools where he
can do so
i feel like using eddie's jabs is key
for that he needs to start using the
jabs yeah right now like dvk he's
getting in right like in the previous
games you know he's playing the range
game he's trying to play that game with
eddie but obviously that's where eddie
wants to play at right yep where miguel
wants to play at he wants to be in your
face and i think cal i think that dk did
a much better job of staying close to
calm that entire game there uh and
anytime he would run up he's like i need
to run up and do like downward one uh
you know he saw a couple of rounds end
that way uh because he's opened up with
these lows now too so you know you
really got calum guessing here and i
totally agree with you i think the jabs
need to come out as like a keep out tool
you know even if it's just like the
downford one one or just the one two uh
whichever one it may be right uh he's
done a good job like sized at four to
keep out uh you know those kind of
keeper tools are working but i feel like
he wasn't doing enough keypad tools uh
side support might be good too because
you know as a keep out tool if he gets
hotkicked or something it's not really
gonna be too much damage
because he might not be a full float
that's true it's all about the range and
how you kind of utilize things but we're
in open stage
and calum decides to go for the infinite
azure
but yeah you know you know that is i
mean it's it's purely for backing up
oh yeah
let's see if you can force that game
play on dvk and keep him out this time
that's gonna be the question mark cause
that was the difference in game three
but dvk up two games to one here just
needs one more to go to the grand finals
and get his run back
let's see girl you look good once you
back that dash up
check that dash off
yup here we go start it off
[Music]
oh counter hit down forward two he was
waiting for that opportunity this time
getting the big launch the follow-up now
we can run
sometimes i run
oh counted oh my gosh going back the
other way oh he lost it
[Music]
what's he gonna do
the follow-up here has a good
opportunity again he does have a slight
life lead
see what he does with it
and yeah he's fishing for that downfall
too
that three two is working man he's he's
gotten it to work quite a bit so far
beautiful
he caught him so off guard with that
relaxed approach
that dvk totally froze
take the trade all day
ran up and killed him here we go
the follow one round calum looking
really good obviously the open stage
definitely helping his game plan oh that
didn't hit
good block
superman
yeah that superman pledge home has been
working out actually it's been a really
good approach to get over the size of
four
oh my gosh stringing them how did you
miss i don't know
power get that power out i'll do enough
damn to kill you
here we go tied up on rounds this is big
because you know dvk if he's able to
take his matches all over and callum
will be out of the tournament but calum
he's still moving with that confidence
that was sick
that was actually so sick he he let dvk
think that they were playing a close
range game when he he's like i'm going
to slow back dash away here boom boom
it's all about creating that space up
close because you know it's one thing to
go back but it's another thing to go
back and then wait for the whiff punish
what is going on
tbk
don't drop it like this oh good block
he's gonna be is he dead i think he's
dead i think he is
no
that didn't hit usually it's guaranteed
trying to clutch it out
good stuff good stuff from calum round
four that's a long leg
standing four able to close it out here
callum looking for an opportunity he
caught him ducking there he flashed like
14 times i love that calvin did that
right just to see what he would do make
him think about it yeah
man i would while standing one three all
day if that's all he did to me
just that little low kick that's it yeah
that's all i'll do i'm down
he's fishing
oh the lows are coming out you know he
blocks that he might get that nice
punish though
dbk has to be careful here
try to catch him
time's a waste in
nice
he's got he's had so much trouble
approaching this this game dvk has
yeah he finally got him in a break but
right when he did he hit that counter
hit down forward too
he's gonna have to be careful again
because right now he's approaching calum
might do it again
in nine seconds rage mode drive spent
poke to keep out he's gonna backdash all
day
oh look at that we're going to a final
match
we're going to a final match of course
we are callum likes to keep things
interesting like this dude
we saw a set earlier with big daddy mike
that went down to the wire now this one
going down as well final game incoming
here
anyone's game to be honest i think you
know that game obviously dvk had a much
harder time getting in uh you know
calvin did a much better job of playing
the keep out game uh the down four twos
were there you know the size of fours
are there uh the slow back dash i really
liked uh early which i talked about
right slow back dash let him whip and
get the mirage for the whiff punish like
that's i think optimal eddie played when
you're getting the mirage with punish on
everybody that's when you really make it
impaired right you're taking off like 35
40 instead of just like little pokes
every time uh so we'll see if you can
keep that going but dbk we're not he's
got to find a way in he like he did a
good job of that in game three but
obviously game four the keypad game was
better so this has been really back and
forth you know the the counter play is
coming through which is exactly we saw
earlier from calum so this is really
cool
all right so we're going to uh another
pivotal match this is important for all
the marbles
one of these two players will move on
one will be out of the tournament in
third place
any any thoughts here i'm not gonna ask
who your favorite is but do who do you
think i mean based on the momentum and
what we've seen so far
any thoughts on on what's gonna happen
the match with dv dbk has kind of been
letting it go
i think he's questioning himself
the thing is it's been very back and
forth the whole way oh yeah
i feel like
you know either calums figured it out
now download's complete or
dbk's gonna make bring this back and
calm's not gonna give up and then we're
gonna final final round so it's either
gonna be like a beat down or final final
round that's my call
here we go
this is where it's all going to go down
oh yeah the last match between these two
and i feel like
again sometimes when you play these
longer sets
there's going to be somewhere like
you're going to eventually
kind of break i mean it gets frustrating
i mean if you're chasing eddie the
entire time and that's kind of what
happened in the last match you're going
to get frustrated and you're going to
start playing differently
so calum actually kind of betting oh my
god he caught him with the relax
double relax in his face and caught him
looking that's one of the callum
specials man
and the f4 they're working out rage mode
now dbk do you have anything no sir
ghost for the downford one two
callum solid life lead there close that
round one
yeah that was strong there's a follow-up
again man i would do that all day
running three this time callum is
playing offensively he's trying to
really throw off dbk
it's working he is actually attacking
but a big counter hit there from dbk
kind of stopped
let's see what he does here
oh that's that could have been doesn't
matter you're punished
nice that 442 able to close things out
one round a piece here again
you guys are going back and forth
it's gonna happen
you think so yep the ffr is gonna happen
you know it
man i don't know if it's jinxing or
blessing
it's always a blessing for us viewing it
he caught him ducking
that down three to three
able to get that launch here and pushing
at the wall no launch punch at all
punishable you got nothing though like
not even anything
yeah he has to try he is at least
attempted because right now calum knows
that he can do that he's gonna get away
with it
oh and a big punish
this is unfortunate for dbk he let that
one go he could have taken that momentum
even further and just like that callum
one round away from moving on to grand
finals
i'm scared man it might be a mid
lava toes
little lava toast yeah we gotta watch
out there's lava
we both have light colored pants can we
come to a truce
right now the only truth oh wait
look at all calum right now dvk trying
to approach tournament life on the line
here he's in range now about the drive
got him this is this is big because it
could be a lot of damage let's see what
he ends up finishing it with what's the
mix
boy howdy back there said that was crazy
i don't know i don't know i'm not big
where was it
oh but he got him trying to come in
again calum holds on
and eliminates dvk from the tournament
three to two nicely done nicely done
congratulations to both of you but of
course that means calum will be
advancing to the grand finals and we
have a rematch of our winner semis from
earlier today it's gonna be
uh big daddy mike versus callum and i'm
excited to see that because they had a
crazy set early on definitely
definitely let's take a look back